maybe trying to get on the side so you
could see it okay so again the drill is
he's trying to shove me back go ahead
he's trying to shove me back okay if the
your partner starts to overpower you
then stop so that they get another
chance okay
you are neutralizing your partner and
stop and let it come here because the
reps change at the ends you understand
yeah
so we'll fill the whole thing we start
on one side of that and his job is it's
not going to be my turn to start pushing
until we get to the other side of the
knife assume we got to the other side of
the map and now it's my job look
starfish's is that so because she might
neutralize the guy so I will be here
he's going right it we're never gonna
get there do you see that so I might
give him a little bit so that he gets it
right and then I'll start again you get
it make you a to get inside the map
again Shirley okay and the same thing if
he's totally overpowering me I don't
want the rep to end immediately so stop
and set up again and go got it again so
this is not a matter of he's pushing me
and doing that this is your key Lavazza
internal aspects done more freestyle but
still a prescribed energy he's trying to
push
so you will combine your skill set so as
he's trying to push I will neutralize
what he's pushing on he goes to push and
I might lift him up with a co2
projection so you can't round you see
that and then of course you have the in
releasing skill because different to
drive you and you're going to get you
tapped and you're going to notice holy
cow we switch now honey so I have to
practice to the releasing so when he
when he Cyclops will be driving me out
relax
okay so
[Music]
don't let me go
so magic we got to the other side if
they're become buck and he has to do the
same thing let's try that but I'm
grounding lifting displacing okay come
on don't let me go come on don't let me
go
are you sure
okay go so see how I'm not letting you
on the ground you see that but it's
because you push you know go ahead
[Music]
[Applause]
don't let me go
[Music]
so see your head see ya every time I
tricky go also you go so see how you
pushed on me
go ahead you gotta keep doing it I'm
gonna keep to it okay so would you push
off me look I'm turning you you see that
and now you push on your shoulder you
see and now I'm going to keep going
right are you trying to get under me
right you see that but I actually go
over you you see what if I were tense up
you actually under me but if I play a
lot of the whole for you you've seen the
difference so now you wanna push on the
shoulder again right okay good and I
stepped into the spot so you want to you
want to push that arm you see that
that's allowing me to get behind you go
here comes the shoulder land moving
around
so sometimes I use it a push against
them she's pushing on me as what it's
allowed me to tilt her you see that
sometimes she's pushing it on my head
I'm taking stock of it see what she does
with it but sometimes I'm I'm teasing it
out of her to see that so when she
pushes on my head oh here didn't do that
you see that instead of trying to fight
that angle right she goes I combine it
with this the arm that she was pushing
do you see that so here she's trying to
go back and because she's pulling down
with my arm I can hook on her you'll
feel it try to push me back and you're
making me heavy because your arms if you
would relax your arms it's very hard for
you to make you feel me I'll show you
click on me
[Music]
take away what is stopping you
so this don't go here right take away
what's stopping you
just like how fighting right not here
and that's not tricking her unless I'm
treating her so this lien is a trick and
not really breaking and tricky as that
money okay try it
so see this see that tension right there
that's that's where I'm patrolling from
your attention you see but my heart is
not tense so if when you move it I can
still move keep going that your
attention picks you up your head you're
trying you're trying to get me under but
it's only gonna work when I when I'm
trying to not let you so I go you see ya
didn't do anything with baby's face
disarms where I'm controlling
so you why can't why doesn't she have
politic she's trying to move me with her
hips that's why you don't have power
because you need to have that hip back
do you see that so I'm letting her keep
her hip there see how it takes away your
leg you see that okay so if I Drive
magazine
right here where you pushing so young
right well did you you see you guys
understand so but it's difficult because
you're used to trying to get in dumb
reconciliation in here but this is just
for us once here just like now I love
them just doing standing there was them
standing slow
try trying to deduce what I'm tricking
her okay meaning I'm using her will to
power and will the preservation against
her do you understand what do you
understand
you see how going around her leg do it
again
you see go but don't worry about me
[Music]
Oh
so it's not my legs right right okay try
the grounding delete the vectoring of
the force down into the feet
the in reconciliation right and
projection I know we did so he's trying
to push me back right same drill he goes
and I used my yin reconciliation to
leave into the technique okay so here
I'm around each so why by grounding why
do you think what yeah I'm sure I try to
trigger it you see that okay so if to
hear me thinks I'm good doing that but
I'm not weird work oh you're alright
okay keep going
what's this what am i doing you know I
don't want you to go fast just like up
you know rolling I'm not forcing
anything you owe me to complete anything
just work on the initial
get to the other side okay play with it
okay some people think that ID does not
you know some manipulation of you okay I
would say it's not younger young
manifestation well it doesn't mean that
what I've been close and actually
engaging to you that I'm in
automatically young too young
manifestations see that so I'm not
restricted in my you know that I have to
do Aikido way out do you understand
so I want you to feel a wind I release
okay
I'll be close to move again I'll find a
little ring so the second one would be
Yong Yong and its image that external
manipulation and the first one
[Music]
start a little gradually so you can feel
your you're started it just just like it
as a dangerously then you'll gradually
feel see they feel that do gradually you
see pressure increase they see and
that's that's a young beyond but you can
do these young too young out here you
see so right so you feel gradually and
you feel me start to change your
relationship do you see see how I'm
doing that
[Music]
okay so that was a good point we shooter
that okay so then what I do I now pay
attention
you see if you relax
that would be hard Oh watch like what am
I do I realize award and now you're
still young to me you see his younger
relative it's you understand so here I'm
doing that absolutely relaxed and I
relaxed more and now you're still young
and now you're pushing for okay you guys
understand okay so for you and for you I
would transition slower okay
so feel okay try it
play play with it more than trying to
win it so easy when you see me do that
that I'm doing like a push-pull setup
like I am drinking him but I'm not
tricking him so he pushed pulls that's
and then when he pushes right I pull or
something like that I'm setting up the
dik adhesion I need some young in order
to do a hidden release to create the
item do you get that that that's
different to me than the bullfighter
when he comes in and goes down on wait
that's a that's a I moved out of the way
and I let the young go through so that's
different then he's pushing at me
come here you see that yeah that's like
I pulled a chair out from under and my
Aikido that's not an idea Asian that's a
good tactic but it's not an I kid he's
an so if he's athletic and he feels Mego
wonder if he he will be able to get away
do you see that so when I say I'm
tricking him I'm not sending him up but
he's he's not giving me any energy so I
can't do the hit release and the I key
is generated by the yen release now I
showed a different thing because you you
went yeah right but I make that a yawn
by releasing more then I got an idea he
Jie okay why is the - he's important
because when I set him up and he
counters it he's able to counter it and
so that's what you're doing is you're
like trying to find the move they can't
counter so you go ahead
don't worry I'll figure it out so
instead you see how we're stuck together
you see we're stuck
[Music]
this is the external which is fine it
works
this is a lot of movement I move he
moves you see
not-not-not I get out of the way go
ahead now I get out of the way
[Music]
see that's different right and you see
how he got his fallacy to come back so
when I when I get I have to keep you did
you get that my so I don't like going
muttering not doing that control
somewhere you're up